I saw this yesterday and I was like I  mean  this couldn't be more perfect okay at  the place that you grew up that sounds  perfectly normal to any local but as  soon as you say it to an outsider it  sounds absolutely insane great question  I'll go first  um in Maine we're taught how to most  effectively hit a moose with our car in  driver's ed you are not meant to slow  down instead you have to speed up as  much as physically possible that way the  Moose will bounce off the hood of your  car and fly over the passengers I feel  like you filmed this for us yeah  that way the Moose will bounce off the  hood of the car and ragdoll often times  flipping three four times and sometimes  you hear the Hooves kind of climb  together  sometimes they make a weird noise dude  [Music]